hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have another review for
you
and that is a usb cable by nordost
uh
i don't know how to pronounce the actual
model number tire 2 or ty r2 uh
uh it's an odd sounding uh name sounds
like a car tire or something
but uh
you're not here to hear my commentary on
naming so let's move on
um the cable um as i mentioned is the
usb cable here's the real thing
i was actually quite surprised of oops
sorry hit the microphone uh i was
surprised of how
ordinary it looks usually these uh
cables expensive cables are dressed
quite nice and this one is not despite
costing 1 400 for one meter cable so
this is the whole thing and uh
is 1 400 uh some of you may think that's
an outrageous amount of money but usb
cables uh just this length go up to
twenty thousand dollars or more so for a
high-end uh cable buyer this is actually
a uh budget one
if you will um for someone like me uh
budget cable is
this uh amazon basics which i use for
everything and it costs less than seven
dollars
including shipping from amazon uh it's
quite flexible uh and easy to use it's
longer than this one
this one as you can tell it's quite
stiff um you may say well don't matter
but
if you try to twist this thing which you
have to to align this this kind of usb
uh connector it's pain in the neck i
mean literally you have to like you know
put ton of force on it to try to bend it
uh i think that's due to the use of
using uh
solid wire in here which is a mistake i
mean something that needs to flex you
don't use solid wire
but that's what they're doing and but
this one of course is stranded it's got
this great feel almost feels like
silicone wire although i'm pretty sure
it isn't because that would be more
expensive but regardless of what it is
it's quite flexible
and it's two meter length unlike that
one that's one meter length
um
i think uh one of the resellers is music
direct and it had this tag line in there
dramatically raised computer audio
performance with one move reference
grade noticed
tire 2 usb cable
enhances sound staging imaging dynamics
detail and precision
of course there's no backup for any of
those but if it does even one out of
five of these things that'll be a great
thing so let's get into some objective
measurements so that
is repeatable data and reliable data
um
uh one thing is a pedantic comment to
make but i want to make sure you all are
careful as you read the advertising for
these cables
none of us listen to a usb cable the usb
cables carrying digital data and that
data then goes to a dac that is then
converting that
much lighter to analog waveforms we
listen to so ultimately the only thing
that matters is the sound waves coming
out of my audio equipment i don't care
what you know what kind of screw they
use to mount things together or whatever
what matters is that you know what is
the sound like at the end of the day
and to do that i grabbed this
topping dx3 pro plus
it's a very high performance uh
headphone amp and dac but only costs uh
200 for the whole package so it's
probably equivalent to a sales tax on on
this cable and shipping but anyway
it's a very high performance very very
resolving uh dac and i just had pulled
it out for another testing nothing
special about it i just you know have
probably 100 different decks in the back
and i just grabbed this one for some
other testing and then i just reused it
for this
normally for testing i use this
shed modi 2 deck
this is
one of the
few and rare stacks i've found that
actually
cares about quality of the usb
power and usb signal in that if your
computer is noisy this thing puts out
noisy stuff if you have five volt
supplies not clean this thing degrades
and so it
turns out to be revealing of differences
in usb cables and indeed i've done a
test like that uh in the past and uh the
winner there by the way was the shortest
capable wins uh on this thing anyway i
try to use it for this and uh
whatever's changing my system or
whatever this thing now was just jumping
up and down in performance and it would
not lock to any meaningful uh data a
sign out would change from 85 to 90. um
so i couldn't take one measurement
change cables like take another
measurement because then things were
changing so much so if you've seen me
use this in the past and you know want
to know why i didn't use a dac that's
sensitive to that is this of course no
good daca design will have sensitivity
to uh usb cables or usb source or
computer activity for that matter
but anyway going back to dx3 pro using
my standard amazon basic six foot cable
2 meter cable
we see that
it has a sine add of 115 db
that means if you sum the noise and the
distortion and compared to the signal
that i gave it which is this tall oops
you can't see my cursor um this tile
signal is what we wanted what we told
the dac to produce and then produce this
other stuff and some amount of noise if
you take all that noise and all of those
spikes together and compare them to this
they're 115 decibels lower
threshold of hearing is 115 decibels
negative from reference so
that tells me that this stack is
completely transparent
to as far as noise and distortion as you
can hear either one of them
if you play at the reference level of
about 115 db to 120 db which is quite
loud
um but again this is with amazon basics
cable um so
nothing special was needed to get this
level of performance
now let's
change the
cable to nordust
and see what happens well nothing
happens
look at even cyanide is still 115 don't
worry about the fractional differences
every run this thing is if you look at
it real time is changing all the time
but essentially it's 115
now and it was 115 before
but even beyond that look at the output
that it puts out 2.170 volts
2.170 volts so
there's just no loudness difference at
all the sine waves coming out
identically again these things also vary
a little bit from run to run look at the
frequency accuracy
1.0005 zeros worth of accuracy as far as
timing
same with my previous days five zeros in
there as far as timing
so
as far as we can tell
uh loudness hasn't changed uh distortion
hasn't changed the noise hasn't changed
uh timing accuracy hasn't changed
not a thing given a hair out of place
with either with switching usb cables
so
we could stop here and say yeah i mean
the waveform coming out of this thing is
so accurate but people complain well you
use just one tone what if you use other
tones and music is not one tone okay i
have a test called the multi-tone that
has
32 tones in it mixed up in a specific
ratio i won't get into
and
i run this test at a 192 kilo sampling
rate so much higher than the previous
one which was the cd rate
and uh the bandwidth therefore is half
of sampling rate always so we have 96
kilohertz of bandwidth so we're actually
including a lot of ultrasonic noise and
distortion
and then i run that test with with with
amazon basics versus nordust and look at
these two graphs they're they're just
landing on top of each other the red is
nor dust and amazon basics in blue the
graph actually looks purple because the
tube mix together
there's a tiny little hair differences
here and there but that's just
run through on variations but you know
if you look at it the top is zero the
bottom is as low as minus 160 db
uh the depth that we go to measure is
just so far beyond our hearing threshold
that's just amazing and even when we do
even when we do that we still don't see
any difference whatsoever
um
but we can zoom in just look at the
noise um here i have everything hooked
up just the way i made the previous
measurements except that i haven't told
the uh the computer to generate the uh
any signal so everything's connected usb
cable is connected output is connected
so we're just looking at the noise and
distortion that's coming out of the deck
and if we do that we see that uh there's
just no difference again between the two
again you could squint and say maybe
there's a hair difference in here but
that's just run to run variations this
is just inherent noise this is inside
the dac inside
the computer wherever it's bleeding uh
on this thing so it really really
there's nothing uh different about the
two codecs and the key thing is also to
notice is the bandwidth of measurements
i've gone to uh one mega sampling on
audio precision which gives you 500
kilohertz of of bandwidth and so we're
going way past audible band our audio
band ends over here but we've gone way
past it for people who think there's emi
rfi differences and this and that well
i've gone 25 times past the uh
you know hearing range there's still
nothing look at the shape of the noise
floor it's the same between red and the
blue and the same spikes exist
everywhere uh look at this garbage at
the end over here that's also you know
in both of them so
you know it just there's nothing there
but again look at how low we're going on
as far as measurement accuracy
so
we can do the same test uh this time
with a wide bandwidth so going back to
that one kilohertz tone instead of just
looking at it up to 20 kilohertz we can
go all the way up to 90 kilohertz
spectrum
and
again we see nothing different in here
the two dags have this the two cables
demonstrate the same output out of the
deck which is all that we care about
now people don't know any better always
come back says well those are all
frequency tests and how about timing
well i won't go into it right now i
think i have another video on timing
but i said all right you want to see
timing tests i'll show you mother of all
timing tests the stack can go very high
sample rate of 768 kilohertz so i set
the topping uh to 768 kilohertz sampling
so we're pushing the data rate on usb
now to far higher rate than 44 so this
is i don't know 25 times more or
whatever it is so the usb cable is being
much more busy right now
now sending 24 bit data at 768 times
768 000 times per channel per second
um and then i sent the square wave to
the dac and
uh here's the analog output um we see
that it's almost perfect it can never be
perfect because the bandwidth that's
required for a perfect square wave is
infinite
we obviously don't have infinite because
the sampling rate is not it's way below
infinite but the key thing is that
there's no difference between these two
cables you might say well this graph is
low resolution
you know what if you zoomed in on the
transition okay here's a zoomed in on
the transition
and you can see that all these little
artifacts are because of the bandwidth
limiting
and
it's the same in both it's just the
cable is not able to influence anything
whatsoever even though i'm going you
know microsecond resolution now in
timing here zooming in just this little
transition
and
uh
there's just absolutely absolutely
no difference
now one test i usually do
is i take a transformer ac transformer
and i
wiggle it around the cable to see how
much 60hz it picks up
most analog cables are susceptible to
that and when i'm measuring rca cables
and what have you that will induce 60
hertz which
shows up uh in these measurements here
you can see there's just nothing here
and indeed that's what i found neither
cable was uh sensitive to this
form of magnetic interference from the
transformer
both the amazon and the
nordus cable were just as good in that
regard which is nice
i got it close to the rca cables coming
out of the stack is it doesn't have
balanced output and immediately i saw 60
hertz go up so
the test is valid this is this
transformer is radiating uh
magnetic interference but um it does
nothing to usb cables in this setup
so another thing i do is you know people
always come back say well i don't listen
to graphs i uh
listen to music and uh you know why why
didn't you do a listening test okay i'll
do a listening test
i uh hook it up the the
first amazon basics uh to it i plugged
in my uh
dan clark stealth which is a four
thousand dollar headphone is uh state of
the art the best headphone i've ever
tested and has exceedingly low
distortion that said the level
distortion in this is rival's electronic
devices is that good um
and uh so i it also blocks outside noise
so you can hear really deep into your
recording
i'll listen to with amazon basics first
uh i have this collection of reference
tracks which you can find on audio
science review
and it just sounded gorgeous and
beautiful and you know you didn't want
anything else i switched them to the um
nor does cable sorry making noise
and
immediately i thought the sound that
more congested and
collapsed you would think you know
here improvement
i didn't
um now going back to measurements what
you weren't supposed to hear and you
think how come you heard something well
to confirm that i went back to the
amazon basics cable and it sounded
better it's like wow there's a
difference
but i didn't stop there i switched back
to the uh nordos cable now the nordos
cable sound is better i went back to the
amazon one and amazon sounded better it
always seemed to be the second one i
listened to except for the first
iteration uh what's fascinating that
whatever i thought was better which was
sort of the the music sounded a little
louder and the highs were a little bit
more clear
it would just fade out that effect over
a few seconds and so when i did the
change again it would sort of peak back
up and fade out so all of this is
obviously
a perception problem we have the sound
waves did not change in either case it's
just that my brain is operating
differently i'm focusing on what's
different and i hear things or listen to
different part of the music that's
playing every in every iteration and
so
you know a proper test like this would
have been blind and then i could listen
for 30 seconds and i'll listen to the
other one for 30 seconds or 30 days if
you want and i guarantee you uh whatever
i thought it was in one i would also
hear it in the other one or vice versa
um so but people run cited tests and
they claim to hear all the improvements
here's my sided test and uh yes i heard
improvements you're not crazy you're not
delusional you're just human so am i you
know i hear improvements that aren't
there because the testing is improper my
brain and perception is different and
it's like a microscope that you you know
focus and tune it then you'll see more
but the object doesn't change in in
either case
on this thing and i tell story about my
wife coming up uh
and the right middle of this testing
telling me that the uh um
you know sounds a lot your story sounds
better and she has to use your question
was your change
uh
i told her well not this time because
there's no way you could have heard what
i was listening to because i had
headphones on and of course uh she knew
i caught her and she was not going to be
able to cash in that chip with me
on anything else and
went downstairs to the kitchen
disappointed uh so
we move along
um so
as you can see i've done extensive
testing in here i've come to to this
thing from different angles different
tests one frequency multiple frequencies
high frequency low frequencies and it's
just there's no difference why is there
no difference well when you buy a decent
uh dac and amp what you're paying for is
that kind of isolation and not caring
about the usb vagaries and even if it
did have problems with usb it would be
the source of the noise and
junk inside your pc what gets picked up
by a cable is so minoud and the cables
these are such short cables that you're
not remotely straining the protocol
itself uh if you had a 30 foot cable
yeah there would be differences one may
work and one may not by the way when
they don't work and i've recorded and
put those clips online you hear static
you hear buzzing it's very clear it's
never a case where the
working cable sound has better sound
stage better depth or everything it
never does that it's just the broken
cable will have buzzing and static and
noise and that comes and goes because it
literally the digital bits are falling
on the floor and but until that if you
just pull back where the cable is
working then all of a sudden
it's done its job uh on this thing so
hardly anyone strings extremely long
cable um
for for their dags i know some people
put a computer in different room and
then
uh run along usb cable in that case you
need just need a good usb cable not an
audiophile one
that frankly there's no proof that this
thing does any better i mean it's not
like the company said oh here's a
30-foot version of ours and look at the
quality of the bits going across
compared to an amazon basics one okay
then we'll we'll go look at that but you
know how many people buy this cable
versus that and if this cable had
problems so millions of people would
complain and they don't they use this
for all manner of things and they don't
complain and uh despite the fact that
this cable was twice as long as that
cable and therefore more susceptible to
losses and degradation
in reality our dax don't care so in a
typical environment where you have a
source streamer server whatever driving
a dac for how you use there's absolutely
no problem in here if you go buy a
proper audio device don't buy [ __ ] modi
2 because of well synopsally product but
at the time it wasn't obsolete a lot of
people think that thought this was a
good tag until i got tested i'm like
wait a second
depending what port i plug it into his
performance changes so
it's it's just not good this thing does
have issues uh
um so it's a lesson there not buying
stuff for which you don't have
measurements uh you know either proper
manufacturers measurements or mine
so
uh please don't spend your money on
cables like this uh if you have the
money use it to buy more music if music
is what matters and go do that
if your ears are the only thing that
matters okay set up a blind test where
you don't know which cable you're
listening to get this amazon basic cable
and repeat the test ten times see if you
get nine times out of ten right of which
cable is which
leave a video recorder running or camera
your phone or whatever so we have proof
of what you did and uh
you could be very very very famous if
you can prove
uh any cable like this would make an
improvement until then the data is very
very con
conclusive
engineering and science of what's going
on is also very conclusive and so uh
don't waste your money on stuff like
this okay i appreciate the owner that
sent this to me and
i'll see you in a future video bye-bye